China just threatened Elon Musk saying
that quote he will be taught in less
than End quotes what kind of lesson is
that and why let me explain see
everyone's favorite tech billionaire
recently took to Twitter to tell the
world his foolproof plan for peace in
Ukraine he wants Russia to redo
elections and parts of Ukraine they
annexed this time with U.N supervision
if Russia loses they leave he wants
Crimea to officially become a part of
Russia as it has been since 1783 he
wants guaranteed water supply to Crimea
and he wants Ukraine to stay out of NATO
sounds pretty reasonable right but the
Chinese Communist party or CCP wasn't
very amused but why China and Russia are
allies and Elon is literally suggesting
Russia gets what they want Crimea and
for Ukraine to stay off NATO shouldn't
China be happy their Ally would get what
they want well no because of that little
free election part of elon's Peace plan
you see the CCP cannot sit idly by while
one of the most influential people alive
throws around the idea of free elections
in contested regions that's because the
CCP is sitting on a few contested
regions of their own Taiwan places like
Tibet and xinjiang that are filled with
ethnic cleansing Mass surveillance and
concentration camps we don't want our
subjects getting any funny ideas about
voting to lead the People's Republic of
China now would we that's why China has
to go on the offensive against
influential voices like Elon Musk if
they don't Elon might start calling for
free elections in their territories too
they hate this guy they have to shut him
up but what you may not know is that
once upon a time Elon Musk was not the
ccp's Arch Enemy No Once Upon a Time
Elon Musk was a darling in China and the
CCP rolled out the red carpet for him
gave him the world treatment and
everyone in China loved him Chinese
people cheered him on as he danced on
stage and Elon repeatedly praised China
for how prosperous their country was but
just as fast as the CCP roll out the red
carpet for musk they yanked it out from
under his feet out of the blue hit peace
after hit piece came out about Tesla
almost every Tesla in China became
recalled and the Chinese public started
hating musk Elon Musk had fallen from
grace in China but where did it all go
wrong what turned Elon from a darling in
China to someone that must be taught a
lesson stay dangerous and let's get into
it
foreign
China isn't threatening people one of
the ways they make money is with Force
organ harvesting Yes you heard thy
rights killing prisoners and harvesting
their organs to sell to desperate rich
people that need an organ transplants
unfortunately this is way too graphic
and gruesome to go over in a public
video so we've just released a private
documentary on Force organ harvesting
available right now to only members of
this Channel and fair warning this is
definitely our most disturbing private
documentary yet and all you have to do
to watch it is by pausing the video
scrolling down and clicking that join
button below this YouTube membership is
where I get to post documentaries every
single month that I've always wanted to
make but can't and members love them and
there's a 30-day refund policy too if
this is your first time joining so you
have nothing to lose and members rarely
request a refund anyways because it's
just that worth it so pause the video
scroll down and click the join button
now now back to teaching Elon a lesson
foreign
invaded Crimea in 2014 and held uh free
elections for Crimea to join Russia it
made China just as uncomfortable as it
does today they stayed on the sidelines
not picking aside when the U.N held a
vote to determine whether or not
crimea's free elections were illegal and
had their Central propaganda department
and yes that's a real thing in China
warn everyone in the media to quote not
to Hype or exaggerate end quote the
elections in Crimea
and under no circumstances was anyone
allowed to say anything comparing the
Crimea situation with the situations in
Tibet Taiwan or xinjiang after all it's
not like the CCP is doing anything bad
in those places it's not like they are
threatening to invade Taiwan on a
regular basis it's not like they've done
ethnic cleansing in Tibet and they
definitely haven't had any literal
concentration camps holding millions of
prisoners in xinjiang no way and they
definitely couldn't let the populations
of those regions even get the idea that
free elections are even a thing they
might start getting excited about
Freedom maybe even start a revolution we
can't let that happen now can we
CCP has devoted Decades of psychological
warfare and propaganda to gain leverage
over China's citizens it's what keeps
them in power that and of course all the
leverage it has over anyone it does
business with just like the once magical
business relationship it had with Elon
Musk
[Music]
in 2019 Elon Musk went all in setting up
Tesla in China and at the time it made
perfect sense China was the fastest
growing economy in the world it had a
massive market for electric vehicles and
the government was offering subsidies
for EVS making it even more appealing
for people to buy them in his eyes it
would have been stupid for Tesla not to
expand into China and of course China
jumped at the chance to work with
someone as influential as Elon Tesla in
China was the ccp's way of showing the
world How Great China was for business
that if the genius that is Elon Musk was
enthusiastic about expanding his
business to China it would only be smart
for other business owners to follow his
lead
so to make the deal even sweeter China
bent over backwards to make building the
Chinese Tesla Empire a cakewalk they
gave him half a billion dollars to help
build his new Factory they made things
like paperwork and turning on running
water for the factory suspiciously
easier than usual Tesla cars even got
special tax exemptions that other
companies didn't
it was like Tesla became China's new
favorite stepchild
China rolled out the red carpet and
started treating Elon himself like
royalty they went so far as to offer him
permanent residence in the country and
it wasn't too long before business was
booming
almost immediately after opening the
factory was producing up to 1 000 cars a
week Tesla EVS exploded in popularity in
China everyone who could afford them had
to get their hands on one and when covet
hit and other car manufacturers were
struggling the government took extra
steps to make sure Tesla had what it
needed to remain successful they had
plenty of n95 masks while other Chinese
businesses struggled to get enough for
even their essential employees and they
provided buses to bring workers to the
facility even offering security guards
to make sure the workers didn't mingle
with the community and get contaminated
but in an instant something changed
maybe the CCP had gotten what they
wanted out of Tesla maybe Tesla had
boosted the quality of their EV
companies to where the CCP wanted it to
be maybe the CCP had finally stolen all
the intellectual property it needed from
Tesla whatever the case may be Tesla
wasn't so useful to the Chinese
government anymore
and now it was time to kick Elon to the
curb
foreign
to China had come with some pretty big
strings attached that the CCP was not
happy with normally China requires any
foreign company entering the country to
go into a 50 50 joint venture with a
Chinese firm back when they were
negotiating with Elon he insisted that
Tesla would have 100 control over their
operations and that no other company
Chinese or International could own a
stake which didn't exactly make them
happy and to make matters worse by 2021
U.S China relations were spiraling to
their lowest point since the 1990s in
China's EV companies had actually
started upping their game so now there
was real competition for Tesla
suddenly the CCP started seeing Tesla as
more of a burden than a benefit to their
plans
and just like that China's treatment of
Tesla did a complete 180. all of a
sudden the media exploded with story
after Story of Tesla vehicles having
issues or that the software in Tesla
cars was being used by the US to spy on
China even though all camera data stayed
in the country more stories went wild
about a woman claiming her brakes failed
even though there was no compelling
evidence for this and conveniently the
central propaganda Department did
nothing to stop these stories even when
Tesla asked them to and insisted there
was no proof
it even got to the point where almost
every Tesla ever made in China was
recalled due to software issues
and with each new outrage Tesla was
forced to bend the knee and apologize
their popularity plummeted in and just
like that the Clock Struck midnight and
the magic was over the CCP had giveth
and now the CCP taketh away which brings
us to today where they're literally just
threatening Elon out in the open on
Twitter which is very ironic because
Twitter is banned in China
foreign
the CCP threatening people who go
against their policies actually isn't
new behavior for them in fact it's
actually common practice but most of
China's threats against foreign
politicians and celebrities don't seem
to amount to much like when Nancy Pelosi
visited Taiwan last August
China made some pretty scary threats and
their whole Eastern military put on a
show to intimidate the U.S into
canceling the trip their foreign
military speaker Joe Lee Jean said that
China would consider the visit a quote
gross interference in China's Internal
Affairs end quote
you should be making diplomatic visits
to Beijing not Taipei and if you keep
this up you're gonna have quote very
serious consequences end quote
but when people ask what those
consequences would be Joe only gave a
vague answer quote if she dares to go
let us wait and see end quote
in the end the visit happened and China
didn't really do much about it
although the threats didn't work in this
case sometimes they really do
John Cena was in Taiwan last year doing
interviews to Hype up Fast and Furious 9
and got into trouble when he slipped up
and said Taiwan was a country so he
posted a video on China's social media
platform weibo with a very enthusiastic
apology
and just in case that wasn't enough to
appease the CCP and his 600 000
followers on weibo he made sure to throw
Tibet under the bus for good measure
um
lucky for Cena that bootlicking seems to
have made the CCP happy and nothing's
really gone wrong for him because of it
but most of the time China just can't
follow through with most of these
threats unless you have family living in
China or something else important to you
like a movie deal or an entire Eevee
Factory
China just doesn't have enough leverage
on you to do anything unfortunately for
Elon he still has a lot invested in
China so he better self-censor about
free elections and freedom of speech or
he will be taught a lesson
these are a big business in China but
you want to know another booming
business in China you're not allowed to
talk about the organ trade see China
realized something there is a lot of
demand for organs on the open market
there are a lot of sick people that need
organ transplants to live unfortunately
the supply for organs is very very low
with the average person having to wait
three to five years for an organ
transplant you know because there are
only so many people out there open to
giving up their organs out of their own
free will so that gets you thinking
hmm we have a lot of prisoners that have
succulent organs available and we don't
have morals why not solve this supply
problem by maybe harvesting organs by
force people on their deathbed would pay
a fortune for an expedited organ they're
not going to care how this organ came
about if it's their own life on the line
so a new industry emerged in China
forced organ harvesting where Chinese
hospitals advertise online they could
guarantee patients organs within the
time frame of weeks not years
conveniently leaving out the fact that
the only way you can time that is by
controlling when the person with that
organ dies but as you can imagine
talking about such a graphic topic would
definitely get demonetized on YouTube
that's why we just released private
documentary exposing China's forced
organ harvesting only available to
members of this Channel all you have to
do to watch it right now is to scroll
down and click the join button below
after you join you'll get instant access
to this one and all our previous private
documentaries that channel members have
been loving this YouTube membership has
allowed us to release videos that we've
always wanted to make on how the world
really works but that just wouldn't fly
on YouTube and it's super affordable too
compared to something like college where
they don't teach you how the world works
at all it's just five dollars a month
and there's a refund policy too unlike
most YouTube memberships so if you join
and you don't think it's worth it email
us within your first month of joining
for the first time and we will
personally refund you for your first
month after your first month there is no
refund so click that join button below
now
[Music]
thank you
[Music]